Ronaldo Messi and Slaton are warming up
before an all-stars football game
Ronaldo gets the ball and passes on to
Slaton Slaton then passes the ball to
Messi and then Messi passes the ball
back to Slaton and many such passes are
exchanged now it was pretty easy for me
to explain this to you diagrammatically
but what if I wanted to explain this to
a computer the computer will not
understand diagrams so we make a small
table on the right with three rows and
three columns we can have Ronaldo Messi
and Slaton as rows and to know who the
ball was passed to we have Ronaldo Messi
and Slaton as columns we all know what's
the variable of but let's assume the
players can't pass the ball to
themselves so these three elements will
be zero there is one arrow going from R
towards M so we write a 1 here and
there's just one pass from Ronaldo to
Zlatan similarly we fill the rest of the
slots what we see here is nothing but a
matrix it is nothing but an array of
elements something which a computer can
decode and it summarizes the entire
warm-up session adding up all the
numbers here will give us the total
number of passes and it also tells us
the direction of the passes don't you
wish matrices were thought like this in
school